you know I think when we were working on
a film we were not entirely sure that we
would find a studio to actually make
this we were doing it on spec on faith
on trust and trying to find the heart of
this that was in the book and minoo the
fact that we were able to find somebody
Jeffrey Katzenberg it Hollywood Pictures
who would allow us to do this is
incredible to have the movie come out
and have such a response at Universal
response is incredible and now 25 years
later to first be with all my friends
and cohorts and to see so many people
still love this movie it's gratifying
why I met her and I told her I really
want to make crazy rich Asians know I I
had just come off of eat a bowl of tea
and I read the book and I loved the book
so I said I have to do this home Amy
crazy Chinese mother that's right
and I dealt with a lot of them unsaid
I'm sure there's love there yeah I got I
read the book before it was finished I
was one of the lucky people that was
handed chapters in manuscript form
before Amy your editor never said I was
in a meeting with Kathy Kennedy I had
just finished working with Steven
Spielberg on the movie Empire of the Sun
Kathy Kennedy and they asked me to work
with them and Kathy Kennedy took me to
New York to hear about the upcoming
books and we're sitting it was at Putnam
I think it was punt and we were sitting
the offices of Putnam and she's talking
about all the upcoming books and then
she turned to me said oh we just did buy
this book we spent more money than we
ever did for a first-time novelist she
said that and she said but it's weird
because we only have three discrete
tractors they're completely unrelated we
have no idea where it's going
but here why don't you see what you
think and I took them with me on the
plane ride home and I was sobbing at the
end and that's when I got in touch with
you and I don't know if you remember
this he started sending me chapters as
you were writing them and I I was a baby
produced I barely knew how to make movie
but I said I'm going to make sure this
movie gets made by hook or by crook so I
didn't know what I didn't know and I
didn't know how difficult was going to
be and I was like we're doing this I
don't know and I kept saying Amy you
have to be involved in the writing of
the script and you're like no I don't
know I don't know anything but then we
business eyes that you have to be
involved in the writing the script so
that was how I got lucky I didn't have a
book in mind I was writing short stories
I didn't know it'd be published and I
didn't think I was a published writer
until it was out so it was all a big
surprise I didn't think I would be a
screenwriter you know as Janet said I
wasn't going to be and and these two
guys kind of tricked me into becoming a
host screenwriter by saying just you
might learn something just stick around
and you know attend this meeting and I
was like typing up notes about what they
were doing and pretty soon I found that
I was part of this process
I met Wayne and Amy they came down to
Los Angeles and had breakfast with me at
the bel-air hotel and after we talked a
little bit they told me they wanted me
to write it in a nice Amy I can only
write it if I write it with you because
it has to have your voice and Amy had no
interest in writing screenplays and
still doesn't but she was we just
wouldn't let her not do it and the one
little anecdote about the difference
between the two medium that I've never
forgotten is she's sitting in my little
office at home and she has her laptop
and she says okay what's first and I
said well this first scene is this
particular chapter why don't even been
the first chapter and I just done a film
with Francis Coppola and in Napa and he
had a computer program long ago but he
had a program which screenplay eyes the
novel we were writing and it proved to
me that it takes four pages of
screenplay to do one page of a novel you
wouldn't think that so now I'm saying to
Amy we have 19 page 20 page chapter it's
really like an 80 page scene
I'm giving us two and a half pages enemy
said well how could we ever do that and
I said because we don't edit it's not
about editing screenwriting
we say what's the emotional core of the
scene how deep can we go before we cut
in how fast can we cut out and I've
never had a better time writing with
anyone